[Musique]
bonjour Julien bonjour Avant de parler
des journaux français et des rapports
des Français à leur voiture la
Grande-Bretagne avec le visage du jour
qui fait la une de tous les journaux
évidemment celui du nouveau du futur
dans quelques heures Premier ministre
britannique Damien j'ai envie de vous
dire cette fois-ci c'est la bonne
regardez ce visage du nouveau Premier
ministre Richie sunac à 42 ans c'est le
plus jeune premier ministre jamais nommé
Hotel dawning Street le plus fortuné
aussi et aussi le premier d'origine
indienne alors on va voir un peu ce
qu'on dit la presse britannique regardez
d'abord le Time conservateur qui revient
sur le discours prononcé hier devant son
parti avec moi c'est où l'unité ou bien
nous disparaîtrons les conservateurs qui
sont divisés entre différents clans qui
sont disons dans une mauvaise passe
surtout en termes de sondage ça c'est
pour le Times si je prends en revanche
des independent toujours le visage de
Richie tsunac non en revanche avec ce
titre assez critique élu nommé Premier
ministre sans un seul vote au suffrage
universel il faut dire que regisuna qui
a donc été nommé par son parti une
nomination tout à fait légale puisque
les conservateurs ont la majorité au
Parlement jusqu'au prochaines élections
générales qui devraient avoir lieu en
2024 Julien on peut pas parler de presse
britannique sont montré quelques
caricatures qu'on a oui effectivement
alors attendez on va juste ici cette
caricature qui est juste là parfois
Damien a des seins et bien vaut mieux
qu'une qu'un long article avec d'un côté
le défi les multiples défis pour les
petits sounda qui sont entre autres de
redresser une économie moribonde je le
disais de tenter de redonner la
confiance à la fois aux parties
conservateurs et surtout à la population
et donc on a cette caricature qui est
extrêmement extrêmement parlante avec un
réticsonac juste ici devant l'entrée
d'un labyrinthe avec l'adresse du
terrain Ding streak et dans ce
labyrinthe et bien on a un peu de tout
on a des vautours on a des plantes
carnivores des dragons et aussi si on
regarde bien juste ici des hommes
politiques avec une mèche blonde qui
nous rappelle un certain Boris Johnson
ouais ça ressemble presque à un parcours
du combattant sur le périphérique
parisien quand on est en voiture on va
parler une voiture avec vous ce matin de
la presse française quel avenir pour la
voiture à l'heure de la transition
énergétique et bien on a un gros dossier
dans le Figaro que je vous propose
aujourd'hui dossier qui montre qui
montre au créneau contre les politiques
restrictives anti-voiture et ce titre
extrêmement précis la voiture bouc
émissaire de la transition écologique en
clair le journal critique les mesures
destinées à restreindre l'utilisation de
la voiture en ville et dans les grandes
métropoles notamment avec des zones
affaiblissement des piétonnisations de
route entre autres dans ce quotidien qui
est juste ici intitulé encore une fois
avec un petit tracé qui interpelle sens
interdit dans son édito et bien le
quotidien affirme qu'il faut cesser je
cite d'empoisonner la vie des
conducteurs oui dit le journal il faut
bien réduire les émissions de CO2 mais
est-ce que ça passe forcément par la fin
des moteurs thermiques prévus en 2035 la
réponse est catégorique pour le journal
et bien c'est non
et en même temps la voiture électrique
c'est une des stars du salon de l'auto
du Mondial de l'auto qui se tient à
Paris c'est une solution l'avenir
effectivement avec cette question est-ce
que c'est une solution d'avenir et bien
pour être tout à fait honnête Damien
c'est très compliqué de répondre à cette
question à l'heure actuelle en tout cas
d'après Le Parisien le problème de
l'électrique c'est déjà son coût une
voiture électrique coûte bien plus cher
qu'un moteur thermique même avec les
aides gouvernementales on nous parle
d'un investissement sur le long terme
rappelle le journal mais oui ça marche
lorsque le prix de l'électricité est bas
sauf que depuis le début de la guerre en
Ukraine et le problème qu'on a avec nos
réacteurs en France et bien le prix du
mégawatt-heure à Bondy et nous dit-on
les usagers font la grimace de l'auto
qui s'attache fait dimanche on reste en
France avec le gouvernement bousculé le
gouvernement bousculait à l'Assemblée
nationale oui avec trois motions de
ceinture censure pardon voter contre
pavoter mais proposer contre le gouver
le gouvernement d'Elizabeth borne après
l'activation du 49-3 notamment pour
faire voter le budget et aussi celui de
la sécurité sociale motion de censure
ardemment défendu nous rappelle
libération par la gauche et soutenu à la
surprise générale vous allez le voir par
le front le rassemblement national avec
2039 voix au final ce n'est pas assez
pour faire tomber le gouvernement et
mets l'effet est réussi le Parisien
parle du coup vous allez voir juste ici
coup politique de Marine Le Pen ça
personne ne l'avait vu venir une sorte
d'alliance des extrêmes entre d'un côté
le rassemblement national et de l'autre
l'opposé du Parlement l'Alliance de
gauche hier il y avait de
l'applaudissement du côté des députés de
l'extrême droite beaucoup de jeunes en
revanche de la part de la nupes pour le
quotidien l'objectif de Marine Le Pen
était de ravir la place de premier
opposant à la gauche et ça c'est réussi
pour l'opinion en revanche tout ça et
bien c'est de mauvaises augure pour le
gouvernement l'opinion quotidien
libérale qui nous parle d'une alliance
contre nature et qui s'inquiète des
conséquences possibles pour faire pour
pour l'avenir pour faire passer l'une de
ces motions de censure Damien et bien il
a justement liker la voix du parti les
républicains cette fois-ci ils se sont
abstenus évoquant plus intéressants à
faire mais un accident est désormais
possible c'est ce qu'on peut lire juste
ici dans l'édito dans l'opinion donc cet
accident à savoir un gouvernement
renversé par un parlement